مشروع قانون جديد حول الاحوال الشخصيه
اثار جدلا وقلقا لدى المصريين تحديدا
ولديهم نيه للزواج قريبا ففي اطار ما وصفه
الرئيس المصري بالحرص على كيان الاسره
ودعمها يشمل مشروع القانون صندوقا خاصا
يمونه المقبلون على الزواج حديثا مواد عده
معلنه من مشروع القانون المثير للجدل توقف
عندها المصريون كتوثيق الطلاق الذي رفضه
الازهر سابقا اي عدم الاعتراف بالطلاق
الشفاهيه ثانيا وجوب اخذ الماذون لموافقه
القاضي قبل اتمام عقد الزواج والقاضي
سيقرر بعض اطلع على فحوصات طبيه للزوجين
للنظر في سلامه المقبلين على الزواج
واهليتهم بدنيا وايضا نفسيا لكن وديعه
الزواج ان صحت تعبير كانت الاشد وقعا لدى
الشباب المصري لما تشكله من عباء مالي
اضافي على الراغبين بالزواج يضاف الى
مصاريف عقد القران من المتوقع للانتهاء من
المشروع القانون قانون الاحوال الشخصيه
الجديد بالكامل خلال الشهر قبل ان يتم
تقديمه للبرلمان المصري